Florida is cracking down on a group of
moving companies accused of defrauding
customers around the country the Florida
Attorney General filed charges in
federal court last month against 14
companies it investigated the movers
faced allegations ranging from damaging
property using deceptive marketing
tactics and even extortion meg Oliver
has been tracking one of the companies
under investigation Meg good morning
good morning
we looked into a company called Spartan
van line after reading through scores of
complaints from customers who claimed
their belongings were held hostage until
a cash ransom was paid many of the
people we spoke to say they had no
choice but to pay while others we met
are still waiting for their most prized
possessions to arrive the walls in
dolores Keens apartment are bare no
pictures of her late husband or children
what do your wedding pictures mean to
you oh my god everything he's gone now I
had nothing to remember him by the
coffee cup that he used to use that I
kept with me you know she hired Spartan
van lied to take her belongings from
storage in Texas to a one-bedroom
apartment in Maryland
Skeen was quoted around $3,500 which she
paid in full but Skene says that after
they loaded her stuff they jacked up the
price to nearly $12,000 eight months
later nothing has arrived in December
the Florida Attorney General filed a
civil suit against Spartan Van Lines
which is named as one of 15 aliases the
company is used since 2014 the
allegations range from using unskilled
untrained laborers to holding consumers
property hostage are they holding your
stuff hostage yeah they want more money
to me that being a hostage
we called three highly rated moving
companies and used schemes to furniture
for a comparison the estimates came in
between six and eight thousand dollars
well below the twelve thousand demanded
by Spartan van line in an email the
company told scheme that if she doesn't
pay her belongings will be sent to
auction there's no reason for this you
know other than people trying to make
money
her misery is echoed across the country
angry Spartan customers like Jennifer
Taylor Behl are still waiting for items
in Illinois when I said no I will not
give you cash I will give you the money
order the man never showed up that's
extortion yes in Florida davina traffic
and her caves and paid an extra seven
thousand to reclaim her furniture and
[Music]
when Amanda Peterson Steph arrived in
Arizona items were damaged beyond repair
this is how they delivered my expensive
TV back to me you consider them bandits
oh absolutely
Pennsylvania senator Dave Argyll passed
a bill to crack down on scam movers he
says the underground market is hurting
legitimate businesses we kept getting
complaints about consumers who were
being ripped off something would be you
know broken in the move some old
artifact from great-grandma and of
course they found out that while they
thought they had hired real legitimate
movers they had hired bandits our goal
says legitimate business owners are also
being targeted
Josh Hall owns a Florida moving company
called Spartan Van Lines he says that
rogue movers are illegally using his
company name definite impact on the
business Hall estimates business is down
50 percent because of the negative
reviews generated by the other Spartan
van line a company that says they're
located outside philadelphia spartan van
line told us their hub with a fleet of
trucks was located here at this
Doylestown Pennsylvania address but when
we arrived we were told all they have
here is a mailbox over a thousand miles
away in Hallandale Florida we tracked
down the company owner Joshua Vaknin he
refused to talk on camera but denied all
accusations of fraud in her empty
apartment Delores is still recovering
from surgery this is your retirement
yeah no personal belongings no no
furniture yeah no clothes no this is it
and you know obviously I can't work
anymore so are you depressed very this
is horrible what this company has done
to people not the only one we reached
out to spartan van line to help locate
Dolores's property they finally told us
her things never left texas and are
still in storage spartans owner told me
her property will not be released until
the remaining balance of nearly nine
thousand dollars is paid in full all of
these consumers are hoping the florida
AG's office can recover some form of
restitution because that case is ongoing
of course she says she can't afford that
money either now it's out to these
people i know is there a website where
you can check to see if your mover is
legit yes and it's moving org and they
ranked reputable movers so it's a good
idea to check that and make sure that
there are no complaints against them
thank you as you can use thank you Mary